after months of speculation and a recent
leak that sent fans into a frenzy the
spider-man no way home trailer is
finally here from what we've seen so far
the film wastes little time in
addressing peter parker's less than
ideal situation following the events of
spider-man far from home in which
everyone's favorite superhero was framed
for the death of mysterio and outed to
the world as spider-man lost in seeking
answers tom holland's peter parker turns
to dr strange played by benedict
cumberbatch who makes a massive universe
colliding mistake using a spell to wipe
everyone's minds and thus make them
forget that peter parker's spider-man
the sorcerer supreme accidentally
contorts the multiverse in the worst way
imaginable a host of recognizable spidey
foes from previous continuities enter
the marvel cinematic universe for the
first time ranging from will and buffo's
green goblin from 2002 spider-man to
jaime fox's electro from the amazing
spider-man 2. that's a tall order for
the novice avenger and the protector of
the sanctum sanctorum but luckily they
may have helped though the rumored tobey
maguire and andrew garfield's spider-man
incarnations have yet to appear in any
promos some viewers believe they've
spotted another fan favorite hero and
the no way home teaser let's break down
who it is and how they may fit into the
story should they actually turn up are
you a public defender
no
despite being pinned as mysterio's
murderer it doesn't appear as though
peter parker is going on the run instead
as the no way home trailer indicates
parker is cooperating with law
enforcement to get to the bottom of this
case maintaining his innocence all the
while nevertheless he can't win this
fight alone meaning he will need someone
to give him a hand in court who better
to do so than marvel's own matt murdock
better known by his vigilante alias
daredevil a whole army of other twitter
users have pointed out that charlie
cox's take on daredevil made famous by
the beloved netflix series could be
hiding in plain sight throughout the no
way home trailer there are multiple
shots of peter parker sitting in an
interrogation room with what appears to
be a legal counsel of his own by his
side slamming his hands down on the
table curiously the person's face is
strangely omitted every time they're on
screen of course when he's not cleaning
up hell's kitchen matt murdock is a
full-time lawyer so his involvement in
peter's case isn't too far-fetched it's
also worth noting that spider-man and
daredevil work together all the time in
the pages of marvel comics meaning the
man without fear could help out the web
slinger with his villain problems at the
movies as well nevertheless cox's
involvement in the project is still
unconfirmed but fans do have reason to
hope that their theories could be
correct the possibility of charlie cox
appearing as matt murdock and spider-man
no way home is both exciting and not
exactly a surprise there's been quite a
bit of speculation about cox being
integrated into the larger mcu but also
a slew of rumors about him appearing in
no way home for instance in december
2020 there were early rumors pointing to
cox making an appearance in the next
spider-man movie then in january 2021
comicbook.com reported that cox had
allegedly wrapped filming for his role
in that project hearsay
can't print any of it without
corroboration can you
and the trail of breadcrumbs doesn't
stop there there was a fresh round of
speculation in july 2021 surrounding the
fact that cox was cancelling gigs at the
same time that the no way home reshoots
were scheduled to take place there have
also been rumors that cox is gearing up
to appear in multiple upcoming mcu
projects including she-hulk and echo if
those rumors are true it's easy to think
that the hotly anticipated no way home
could make for a perfect reintroduction
and that's not all according to variety
when the deals were inked to bring
live-action versions of marvel
characters like daredevil and jessica
jones to netflix there was allegedly a
stipulation that those characters could
not appear in any other capacity until
two years after the cancellation of the
netflix shows they originated on matt
murdock and his alias daredevil pass
that milestone at the end of 2020 which
would seem to mean that marvel studios
is totally free to welcome him back to
the mcu we'll find out either way when
spider-man no way home hits theaters on
december 17 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man no way home are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]